attention les propos une minute les
parties mesdames répartie le ton est
donné ici à maurepas pas de place au
repos pour les vacances ici c'est
fitness deux fois par semaine le mardi
et le jeudi de 18h30 à 19h30 et on en
ressort avec le sourire
personnellement j'ai adoré surtout la
partie box frappé le prof c'est génial
c'est le trouvais ça vraiment super ça
défoule bien et le dernier pour que j'ai
fait franchement j'ai eu mal pendant
trois jours donc non c'est mon cours box
cardio renforcement musculaire les
éducateurs sportifs sont là pour vous
faire transpirer avec un seul objectif
maintenir la population en forme de
confinement ça n'a pas été évident les
salles ont été fermés et les
associations ont été fermés beaucoup
l'ont lâché l affaire avec le sport les
kilos ont été pris ont été stockés on
est là pour déstocker tout ça et puis
pour reprendre progressivement le sport
pour la rentrée en espérant que tour à
chaque séance une dizaine de
participants se déplace pour cette
initiative organisée par la ville
cette activité s'est mise en place en
fait dans le but de promouvoir
l'activité physique surtout en cette
période estivale où les associations
sont en pause donc l'idée donc c'est de
proposer aux mort passe bien donc la
possibilité de pratiquer une activité
physique donc testé roulait donc qui se
déroule donc deux fois par semaine le
mardi et jeudi durant une heure animée
donc par les éducateurs sportifs de la
ville
les séances sont gratuites et se
déroulent jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août
avenue de vendée